-A lot of pundits,
some people
who are already running
are warning about this idea
that if the Democratic Party
goes too far left,
that will enable a Trump victory
because people in the center
will flee to him
out of fear of the left.
-No, I strongly disagree
with that.
I think one of the reasons
that people like Trump
get elected is so many
working people
and lower income people
have given up
on the political process
and they don't vote.
And compared to other countries
around the world,
our voter turnout is not
particularly high.
And I think what we need
are candidates
who speak to ordinary people
who today are in a lot of pain.
All right?
We don't talk about it enough.
You got mothers all over
this country
who cannot find quality
childcare for their little ones.
We have kids who are graduating
college
$40,000, $50,000, $100,000 debt.
Others can't even afford
to go to college.
We got people who work in
two or three jobs
while we have the
three wealthiest people
in this country owning
more wealth
than the bottom half
of the American people.
We got to raise that
as a moral issue.
When we have so many people
in poverty,
so many people uninsured,
is it acceptable that so few
have so much money
and so much power?
And I think when you start
talking about those issues
and you say, "Yeah,
I understand you can't make it
on 10 bucks an hour.
I understand that you're worried
about the future generation,
worried about whether your kids
are gonna have
a lower standard of living
than you have.
You're worried about
climate change."
When we speak to the needs
of working people and we say,
"Yes. We are prepared to take on
Wall Street
and the fossil fuel industry
and all of the big money
interests
to create an economy
that works for all of us."
I think people say,
"You know what? It's about time,
and I'm gonna go out and vote,
and I'm gonna support
those candidates."
That's my view.
-You had a --
[ Applause ]
Obviously,
there were so many things
about your last campaign
that were successful,
but ultimately you didn't win
the nomination.
One thing that people reflecting
back would say
is that you did not have
a diverse enough coalition
of people behind you.
How have you addressed that
moving into this?
-That's a very fair question.
We ended up --
You know, one of the problems
with the last campaign
is when we began, you know,
I come from a very small state.
I was not known
by a whole lot of people.
But as the campaign progressed,
we did much better with
the African-American community,
with the Latino community,
and we did better in general.
And by the time
the campaign ended,
what I'm really excited about --
we want to build on --
is that we ended up getting
more votes
from young people,
black, and white, and Latino,
Asian American, Native American,
than Clinton or Trump combined.
That's pretty good. Okay?
So, what we --
but your point is right.
You know, we started off
with a few people from Vermont,
and the campaign
moved so quickly.
We did not put together
the kind of diverse campaign
that we should have,
and this time we will,
in fact, do just that.
-I'm glad to hear that.
I heard you say, you know,
one thing you might do
is obviously you're running,
as you've established,
a pathological liar,
as we try to establish
every night.
[ Laughter ]
I've heard the joke you're gonna
bring a lie detector onstage,
at a debate.
But in reality,
how do you run against
someone who --
Obviously, you're very left.
You must be aware that Donald
Trump would paint you
as even farther left than that.
-You know, Seth, here's the --
I never use the word left.
-Yup.
-I don't -- I am.
I'm a Democratic socialist.
So, that's the way it is.
But the issues
that we talk about,
is it left to say that
in this country
we should have minimum wage
that is a living wage?
Is it left to say that everybody
should have healthcare
as a right, that we should
expand Social Security?
Because so many of our people
can't make it --
elderly people can't make it
on $12,000, $13,000 a year.
Is it left to say
that we have to rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure
and create millions
and millions of jobs?
Is it left to say we have
to address
the crisis of climate change
or that we have to deal
with criminal justice reform
or immigration reform?
We have to deal with sexism,
racism, and homophobia.
I don't think
those are left issues.
You know, I think sometimes
the media
makes a bigger deal about it.
I think, in fact,
on all of those issues and more,
sensible gun safety legislation.
I think you have
the strong majority
of the American people saying,
"Yeah, I agree with that."
And let's have people in
Washington who stand with me
rather than just wealthy
campaign contributors.
That's kind of what
this campaign is about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You obviously
have a very good job.
You're trying to get
another very good job,
but you also had
some other jobs.
We found a clip.
You were in a movie in 1988.
[ Laughter ]
A real movie. A real movie.
-Oh, no.
I got to get going here.
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-It's called
"Sweet Hearts Dance."
A real cast, Jeff Daniels,
Susan Sarandon.
-Susan, yeah.
-How do you end up in this film?
I should notice --
your character's name
is Bernie.
-Yes.
-Are you playing yourself?
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't that we did a lot
of auditioning for the film.
[ Laughter ]
it happened to be that the film
was shot in Vermont.
That helped. And they went --
I was Mayor of the city
of Burlington.
We helped them out getting some
extras and so forth and so on.
So I said, "Hey,
I'm a good extra. I'll do that."
[ Laughter ]
That was about it.
-Well, we actually have --
we have a clip,
and I really think you're great.
Let's take a look at Senator
Sanders here
in "Sweet Hearts Dance."
-My acting career.
-Hi.
-Trick or treat.
-How you doing?
-Trick or treat, Bernie.
-Trick or treat.
-Okay.
-Come on, Bernie.
Fill them up there.
-Okay, here you go.
-And let me just say --
[ Laughter ]
-Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think -- I think
that's an Oscar award.
[ Laughter ]
-That was fantastic.
[ Applause ]
-I think it was great.
-And I think that --
I really like that the clip
is you distributing out candy
fairly.
-Free candy.
[ Laughter ]
Free. Right, absolutely.
-No one should have to
pay for their candy.
[ Applause ]
Give it up for Senator
Bernie Sanders, everyone.